ap ap ap ap ap ap ap on ne parle pas
maintenant je goûte car
il manque quelque chose à tout petit peu
de bananes
voilà
je malaxe très fort
et je roule ou talent
c'est presque parfait encore un soupçon
de confiture de fraise
voilà voyons
sans unis facturent vraiment bien j'ai
le coeur qui bat fort qu écouter oui
c'était pouvant
occasionner
casimir tu préparé et que je vis bull
gars hyper jai ho oh non c'est un clown
pipo gars hyper super g 20 oui parce que
ma tante adélaïde et mon coeur qui bat
se sont invités à déjeuner ou mais
c'était pas trop où on va pouvoir enfin
faire leur connaissance c'est formidable
on entend souvent parler mais on les
encore jamais vu écoutez moi je vais
mettre ma plus je lire en bas à tout à
l'heure rendez-vous au kiosque oui bah
ce sont les enfants qui vont être
contents oui moi je les aime beaucoup
mais enfin personnellement je me serais
passé de leur visite casimir moi je
croyais que les ados rhin mais oui mais
s'ils ne venaient pas je pourrai manger
tout seul c'est hyper une bible
pour sur casimir tu ne changeras jamais
ah
mais oui ah mais non
pour quel dommage au revoir
qui était ce tu as l'air ennuyé c'est
rien de grave au moins ses tantes
adélaïde et oncle archibald qui ne
peuvent pas venir déjeuner au sens c'est
dommage c'est vrai que tout le monde se
faisait une joie de les voir c'est julie
qui va être déçu pour van julie enfin
moi au moins je vais me consoler
commente jean monribot ya
quasiment fois tu m'en trouver quelque
chose à faire oui mais quoi bah oui quoi
quoi je crois avoir une idée à lui on
est tous les moutardes c'est ça mon nom
vu que je me remets mais je papote on
subit boulga laissons tomber nono tu
devrais aller trouver ta malle magique
et lui demander d'être transformés pour
quelques minutes d'abord en tante
adélaïde et ensuite en oncle archibald
ça c'est une action anti gay n'est ce
pas mais il ya quelque chose qui ne va
pas et ne sera jamais imiter leurs voix
aux mais qu'à cela ne tienne rôle à
l'amour je les connais bien l'oncle
archives allaient faire leur place je me
placerai derrière quasiment
j'imite rennes en bois mine de rien vous
savez c'est un domaine que je connais
assez bien formidable excellente idée
reviendra bien j'ai vu que ça marche ça
marche par les
formidables
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous croyez que je vais leur plaire dans
cette robe sur des problèmes à pau
est-ce qu'ils vont bientôt arriver
qassimi notion de temps julie devons
indiquer aux je vois oncle archibald
derrière le kiosque je vais le chercher
voilà alors attention petite malle
magique grand forme mois en oncle
archibald
et voilà vous êtes préfectoraux rue pour
aller à leur attention cachez-vous bien
derrière moi d'accord
un jour les enfants
bonjour france mof bonjour juive
aujourd'hui la chine va rester là si mes
enfants accès facile bien beau début
continué
pour la jeunesse
moi aussi j'étais jeune
je me souviens c'était au milieu olala
je ne me souviens plus très bien en le
poids des ans rooney la cause des
facteurs enfin comment archibald et h&m
il est quand même pas gâteux alors c'est
ça c'est fini dit au revoir et on s'en
va
voir mes enfants au revoir bientôt
bonjour chez vous pas restez à votre
place est ce que je suis en avance car
le pauvre oncle arsenal n'a plus tous
ces esprits du trouve au nom illégal car
il est alerte et très bien ben oui
merci magique un bon alors cette fois
appliqué vous mais je m'applique
toujours bon aller allons-y
bush ou récents
changements de délais ainsi mes enfants
ça ne vaut rien de casimir a souvent
parlé
quand il était tout petit il était 6 min
ce mignon
c'est un veau rien c'est pas vrai tante
adélaïde madore dit autre chose
il fait beau aujourd'hui du
moins bons qu'ils font sur
voyant
[Applaudissements]
et plus de ça
alors oui c'est casimir j'entends rien
avec cette perruque à ces temps à
adelaïde excuse-moi tan tan et ses
tantes adélaïde